hello everyone as you are waiting for
the last person hello everyone yeah okay
speaker okay great
as we're waiting for the last person or
some links issue on route to take a bit
of time savings because you can take a
bit of time to build of our inverse like
channel
[Music]
[Applause]
so hi everyone we will talk about how to
set up development environment for
machine learning project
I'm Stephanie I've been a software
engineer for six years I have a strong
interest in automation good quality
automation and good quality hi I'm Sara
so I'm working with Stephanie
so I'm more of a data scientist so I'm
not just software engineer I am have
some interesting some of this issue was
focused on all this that as I entered
machine learning stuff and actually when
I was working on my machine learning
program I've got some recurring issues
which is like how can I brush on things
how can I crash on my data and also I
really like to use drip down that books
for exploratory analysis and I want to
version that but I want version that in
a sustainable way
I don't want you appendage I've done
that books two months after I'm like
nothing's is running and everything's
broken and that's no use I want to be
able then after these exploratory steps
to be able to automate the pipeline in
execution and to ruin it with new
hyperparameters very easily and that's
also something job Tabuk is not so good
at because you tend to have like
multiple copies while you're changing
your learning rate and then you're just
virtual and everything in the name of a
notebook and it's really messy so it was
like I need some help with that and then
I want to be able to reproduce easily
the experiments I run invest and share
them with other people about data
scientists really easily and that was
how things were when I rather people
dark as ourselves that the scientists
there was nothing to set up okay I need
to set up something
so we start we'll start with a pipeline
and data versioning issue H is my drive
typically look something like that so
I've got some CSV data and I've got a
lot of versions and I try to put in the
name of the file what is in the data but
then two months after I'm not sure if I
should use the finer of a final two or
is the final two something I tried but
they don't really work it's really messy
and get a lot of problems also that's
some that trickier which is I managed
maybe you know some solution like each
large file system to version large files
as the name says and so maybe I managed
to achieve version that properly and
I've got this like raw data and then
purposes data but then if you other look
you see that the purposes that I was
actually hold are older than the raw
data so I probably forgot to rerun the
purposing step when the row that I was
updated and that's another thing which
is which I would like to automate and
avoid like any risks of inconsistencies
and just being in your pipelines unlike
what did I do to get this result because
it was a nice one I want to have it
again but I've got no clue how I did it
so that control box it's a new path open
source version tools for that I machine
learning project and other projects it's
a tool for that and that I scientist
made by data scientist it's available on
github and you can find a nice video
about oh it works we can see it now
because we don't at the time but we will
share this like link so globally ODBC
works it's a versioning tool I help you
to
tomato pipeline inversion intermediate
results and all the results under
experienced management as you can do
with kid punches and it's a tool to
share pipeline with your teammates
I will not enter and details on GBC
features because we will show you how it
works during the tutorial but you can if
you have question do not hesitate to ask
your session just to illustrate how it
works we can imagine we have a pipeline
with a really time-consuming task at the
beginning which is a data extraction
step it produced some raw data then
there is a pre-processing step which
takes as input some IP parameters and
the raw data and it produces pre-process
that are and etc until we regenerate the
matrix so your GBC version all
intermediate results and for example if
you want to change some API parameters
and reproduce the matrix you just need
to say to GBC I want to rerun the
evaluation step and you don't need to
care about which step I need to run
first and which step is outdated detect
them automatically and only rerun needed
steps so you you avoid to rerun
time-consuming tasks and you don't need
to remember which step we need to run to
to reach a target so now we will talk
about Oh GBC works
the main common is the GBC run and I
will switch on the tutorial part yeah so
there will be two main part of the
tutorial so the first is an introduction
on how to use DBC because we use it in
ml virtuals and the second part is more
focused and actually using our open
source project which is ml virtuals
and there's a lot of materials in both
of these tutorials so we won't cover
everything but we hope that you will get
enough to get started and then be able
to continue at home if you're interested
and we're also available so the rest of
the weekend and then afterwards by
emails if you've got any questions on
the tutor or something which is now
working or not clear it'll be clear in
the clear enough explain Clary enough
explain what kind of things so everyone
I'm every twitch tour repository but we
will walk on it
so if you can just go in the in this
directory and I will say to endure but
just if you if you can build the images
before I begin to talk will get will
gain some will able to was time and also
linger in the slack already so as I said
in these two terms the aim is not to do
everything all the first steps but after
that we will you will have an
environment to to do your own
experiments and to be familiar more
familiar with division oh it works to
demystify mechanism so the aim of this
tutorial is to create a pipeline with
GBC then to show you how to reproduce a
pipeline with some input changes then if
we at the time we will set up GBC remote
storage to be able to collaborate with
your teammates
I just won or containers so here we have
an environment with two users GBC Saba -
oh sorry
- does it uses about for the step where
we will setup EVC remote storage and a
git server to a git repository so yeah I
will show you the four containers
you know the get server is the TVC
server and at the bottom such users but
you don't need to go on all containers
you further tutorial you just need to
run the first user as it is described
yeah and if you get any problem just
raise your hand or you can try and come
and try it well okay so yeah I will just
display the size of the git repository
and get server the other size at the GBC
repository on the GBC server and yeah I
can connect to the first user which is
son Goku okay so the first step it's in
the directory then to grant the gift
project
which is a I'm cheap to go inside this
project
okay
now the first step is DBC is its what
it's to be in a gate project then to
initialize this project which we visit
it's pretty simple you just need to run
you see in it and now if you're running
its touches you can see you have some
GBC configuration file we need to add
them don't commit okay so is this good
for anybody to set up the gate and the
division yeah okay wait do you need some
help so things are in the general
channel you have the repository to run
and the linked to go back down it's so
what you're doing for now is this this
tutorial this part of the tutorial going
step by step on this
in the markdown part of the tutorial you
have some details you can expand to see
if you your configuration is okay
is this setup of a joker okay for
everybody or some problem having some
people have a problem with docker
compose
yep
to run the ducal compost we'll come on
you need to be in this directory
yeah can you raise your hand if so do
compost build step is okay okay okay
during this time I just will introduce
so who has been able to set up GBC and
the git repository yet a few people a
question
who has some air on the dock a compass
but it seems to be kind of working
yeah I will explain you what will be the
[Music]
what will be as a pipeline we will use
in this tutorial
so it's really a simple pipeline there
is no link with machine learning it's
just to show Oh
GBC under a pipeline so we will have to
two inputs which are some files I will
show you what is in Zeus's boots and
some parameters the first step just come
cuts input files then generate an
encrypted file and the second step takes
some parameters and the encrypted file
to decrypt it I'll show you the files
we have some characters in both fires
okay it seems it's encrypted and some
parameter it's not really an encryption
it's just some current shape them you
will see so as I said there is some
checkpoints each time in the tutorial to
see that's okay and now if you can raise
your hand if the captain possibility is
okay maybe maybe you can talk about a
[ __ ] but our TVC is working the idea is
something which is walking alongside get
so gate will be used to run all of your
code and like normal stuff you put in a
normal software engineering project and
dvc will be something alongside to
version your data because you don't want
to put your 3 gigabytes files in to get
obviously because it'll break everything
but you also want to have to keep in
sync your data files and your code files
your regular of things and so how do GBC
do that it generates each time metadata
file maybe you have some here you see
you so it's all the metadata files are
like ended with GBC as an extension and
these are the size GBC is using to
version your data alongside of kids so
git will version this DVD metadata files
and all your dot P I bash files and so
on
and GBC will manage to have a cache
mechanism from which if I can take the
metadata files and recreate real data
files and that's basically the idea and
so every time you do something on kids
you should do the same on DBC so like do
I get in it then you do a GBC in it when
you do a git checkout you do a GBC check
out because you have to keep these two
mechanism in sync at all time I don't
know if you want to add something maybe
I will you can just to show all the
steps yeah in fact if you add the folder
when if you just add file by file the
dependencies on the file if you add the
folder the dependency will be on the
folder so if you add something another
file folder steps in relation with those
dependencies will be updated so if you
add file by file the step is out that
she'll only if you make a change in the
file maybe I can just run this free
comments to show you do you submit that
our files
so just remember I'm in the get
repository and I just added inputs data
and I I will track them with DBC
so I just need to run a GC add data
inputs so parameters for example we we
need here to add juice files because
they are pipeline input files we don't
need to do it for intermediate files so
if we run a good status you can see we
have a data repository I will and sorry
I will and when all the ODBC odd
oops okay
if I add the data repository we normally
if I do that without any DBC action
before I will add I will track the data
under get its what I don't want to do
but if I do that there
oops and I wanna get statute statues you
can see ya that are not trapped why
because when you run a GV c ad it will
create a DV Samhita file which takes the
name of the input plus extension the GBC
and it creates a glitch in your file and
in this kitchen you can see there is the
real data file parameter the design part
one touch input partial data input and
if we look in meta file
it's a in an internal division mechanism
all version of the file is identified
with ash and ash and and there is a real
path to the data and if we go deeper in
the dead GBC directory oops there is a
cache directory and in this cache
directory you can find links to the real
data so if we go in 9 like the true
first character yeah you can find those
are part of the - if we just pray that
you can see it's a the this version of
the parameter of the chosen file
but you don't need to understand all of
that you use division because I don't to
compose build now where is it okay for
everybody yeah so and the people who
manage to get the Joker did you manage
to in it the GBC repository and adver
input good great okay so we are I'll
show your screen or something so now we
answer the GBC unit-step commands that
is run we are the project is set up with
division we can begin so you can just
get the input data run the GBC add and
then commit the GBC metafiles so now if
I wanna get like I can see my commits
and if they are any good statues it's
okay everything is tracked is it okay
hello for the first step we will which
is the concatenation the fight
concatenation we need to get the script
you just need to create a step directory
and copy the script for more sources so
this script is just a Python command you
can just do something like steps can cut
file - H it's a Python command which
take as input an input directory and it
will produce an output file which is a
concatenated file we can see it's
produced in Perl Python code ok so now
we will add this file and commit it so
this file it's cut file so it's tracked
with yet no ubc yeah and now we will run
the GBC step so first we'll create a
intermediate result directory and it's
reduce to rights in fact you need to
provide to GBC a command which is in the
step one variable and you need to
declare dependencies and outputs so you
will create a step which know which are
the file you need to run and what you
will produce it's like that you will be
able to know if a step DVC will be able
to know with that if a step is outdated
or not they use that to create this
dependency graph you seen at the
beginning maybe you can show and so now
you're turning in this first steps
you've got two input and one output and
so we can build the graph
and under automatically when your
outdated dependencies afterwards but
when you build it yeah a bit tedious to
write you need to declare dependency
yeah but you also need to provide it as
input of the script you need to take up
outputs and you need to provide it as
the output of the the Python script but
now we can run that okay so if you run
it tree you can see there is a new file
in intermediate results you can just
display it okay it's some characters no
surprise it's just a con yet does
everybody we managed to set up the DVC
go to this encrypted file good good good
so now is any question
if I run I get statues I can see there
is a new metadata file and there is some
data I just can run just add everything
we're gonna get statues and I can see
only God files but no data file are
tracked with yet once again thanks to
the gauge in your file and I can commit
this first step execution
just to show you that so the compass is
working yeah if I push the results so
I'm working on the master branch but if
I push the results you will see the this
number will increase oops I made a
mistake sorry okay now it's 288 do you
have question do you need some help yes
okay yeah
in fact do you see do you see walks
which gets you you will continue to and
all your project like you you do an
project cut whisk it for all the
parameters files no I mean for I mean
get in your files or cut file something
like that but file consider as inputs
data in the pipeline and all with GBC so
the real file go in the GBC storage and
to each data file there is a method of
data file which is associated and this
metadata file isn't all under yet like
it's done in get large git LFS with this
mechanism you will be able to I don't
know create a new experiment check run a
check out on a new branch change your
data so a new meta file will be
generated and this metal file is tracked
under get and if you check out your
project on another computer you will
have just met our file under get and
then you can run a CVC check out it can
go to read the the metafile to get the
corresponding ash and check out the
right data yeah yeah for now in this
step the data is just in the cache with
the director is the GBC slash cache
directory and when we will set up the
GBC remote storage that i will be store
here in this in the GBC server
yeah there is a risk of inconsistency if
you forget to to track metadata for the
in fact it's the purpose of this
tutorial for now we'll just want to show
you all the vc works and why it's a
great tool but it's really tedious to
set up there is a lot of risk of
inconsistency so so that we develop ml
visuals to shoot under and set up easily
set up your project with DBC from a
Python script on Jupiter netbooks okay
so it's okay for everybody for step one
so after step one comes step 2
so now we will decrypt this file so once
again you need to get the script from
the resource directory and we shall need
it okay
it's just a Python script the Python
command which takes as input an
encrypted file and a parameter file and
which creates a result file so here we
have the DC command so once again
gv7 manage these dependencies encrypted
file Jason parameter which are also here
provided to the the Python command and
the output file
now when when you will look at the
results file result file just be sure
you don't assume too much new terminal
yes
it is a second step okay for everybody
can I just praise the results okay it's
a sad Unicom that maybe maybe there is a
teammate we will apply a penis
I don't know I don't know if we will
have the time
so once again if you wanna get stitches
you can see there is a new kitchen your
file and the new meta file you can add
them then couldn't meet them if you run
a good show just to to really show you
that there's no data on your commute you
can run a good show on your previous
commit and yeah you can see there is no
Unicom just metafiles
yes
with it will be a step without
dependencies so nothing come out that it
will be never outdated if in fact if you
I will show you that if you change a
dependency file you can run after that
GBC state choose to see which step
outdated and it will say it's not okay
yeah well even if you don't want to be
stitches you will just say I want to
reproduce this step it will look at all
step in dependencies and women
to continue in the Ischia part you can
display you can display your the
pipeline with the GBC common which is
GBC pipeline show with the - - ice key
arguments on the last meta data file you
which correspond to the last step of the
pipeline and the whoo you can see part 1
and part 2 stages which responds with
pipeline inputs our inputs of the file
encrypted the GBC steps and using
parameter and the final touch it our
inputs of the result the result steps
so is it okay for everybody for the the
next part of the tutorial maybe I will
just show you because we don't have a
lot of time and uh but you you can
reproduce it and do not hesitate to send
us emails if you have a question of if
you are stuck in some part of digital so
like I said the the aim of this is to be
able to reproduce a pipeline easily and
as there is a GC repro command
so now if I run GBC repro and I provide
it to this command the meta file
corresponding to the last pipeline step
I can see nothing happen because there
is a cache mechanism and no all step are
not outdated but I can force the rerun
disable the cache with the minus F
option and everything is rerun but now
if I change some data in the JSON
parameter file oops okay so I can say
color or shift is 165 okay if I run a
GBC stitches it says that the parameter
the JSON step stage is outdated
it's a pipeline input and so the result
stage is already too because parameter
decision is an a dependency of this
stage if we just have a look
at the pipeline schema here you can see
permit of the design file you can input
of the ticket steps which is a result
that takes like that do you see step now
if I we add pipeline inputs oops ironic
it's that shoes I can never do life
cutting I go to the zoo meta file is
modified
I can run a diff on it there is a new MD
suck and sorry 95 and now if I say today
visa to reproduce the results that
without menus as option I can see every
understand it understand I can see the
results I'm really not happy with this
result and uh as DC's working with git I
can just run a git checkout
that's the oops I broke my neural
network moment so there's no more
modification and the primatology the
metadata and result metadata but if I
display my unique on it's still not the
right result it's just because each time
run a git checkout you need to run a GBC
check out so we can wait metadata files
and recent data will data file yeah if I
only see stages
it says hours changes DC check out I can
just play again my Unicom okay so we're
gonna stop here for DBC so if you want
to continue of a tutorial at home later
there are two additional step in this
tutorial which is about setting up
remote data storage so remote quote
unquote because it will be like just
another docker into the compost but that
could be anything from Google storage
ows or SFTP file storage if you want to
keep your data private all that kind of
things and then now you can collaborate
using this remote storage across
teammates so that's really like a
playground you can use to try to rerun
derstand our GBC rocks and so yeah we'll
be happy to hear if you have to like
some questions when you're playing with
this thing and so as you can see DBC is
a very very powerful tool and we're very
glad to see that you find this tool but
it can be a bit tedious to use in the
day-to-day so even if you've got already
everything set up in command lines steps
you have to write all the dependencies
and the outputs and usually like your
command line step take input and output
so you have to write everything twice
and be sure that you don't like any
typos or else your reproducibility will
break and you don't want that
and so we Stephanie we started to think
about what we could do to make it easier
to use especially for like that the
scientists we don't want to do so much
of thinking about like bash fireballs
and that kind of things and script
always break what something easy so we
developed this command which is called
gene DBC and help you to generate a DBC
file and so this script on the Scout GBC
file is an executable file you can then
just run it as a command and so that's
very easy to use the other thing we add
was this Jupiter Network problem also
called Chadwick problem
which is like Jupiter and that boosts
can be very great but we're not
sustainable if you want to go all the
way to production because they're hard
to version I mean every time you rerun
it you've got like slight change which
are most of the time noise so if you
want to commit them like that it's
always changing and messy because you
don't have exactly the same vinyl
version as you have a person of a kind
of things if you want to do some unit
testing it's terrible and if you're
working with a software engineer and
don't do any testing you be like ok
write some tests and we don't write
venom Jupiter networks and if you just
try to like copy paste your code from
Java notebooks to a library it tends to
get out of think it's hard to debug so
you want something which is more
automated on that and so that's why we
have this IP ynb to python command
so obviously you don't have to say it
out loud to use it yes but with text
only you can create a parameter able and
executable script from the Jupiter
netbook we don't really have the time to
go deploying the EP ynb to Python come
on yeah but it will create a a Python
command with some parameters you can run
it with the minus H in your terminal and
C arguments and the older code will be
in a parameter table configurable
method function
sorry and that you come with a EP ynb to
Python you can disable no effect
statements and I don't know if it's
possible with AUP text but we before
developing this common way we I don't
have a look what is existing and if you
ynb to python is built and under convert
from capita yeah and so basically you've
got from this and that work to the
scripts and then if you extra lazy we've
got this magical command which is like
you go from the netbook directly to the
DVC command and then you can just
version things quite easily so that's
the second part of a tutorial so it's
totally independent from the first part
so even if you got a problem with docker
on DBC you can start again so the link
is the second one on slack so that's the
set up project oops part and so you can
setup there's a joker if you've got some
problems or you can set up your favorite
virtual and volkov and then we've got a
requirement file which we can you can
install if you want you can run this
just to build it and start it and go to
the Twitter directory and if you hate
dockerills because it's never working
worked on your right on your computer
just create just well Cooper Ross is in
in a separate repository we call it some
books but you know you need to to go in
the MLV tutorials get root directory
yeah so there should be info TV supply
can so you could need to go at twice I
think or once just you can shut down
your docker compose
I know you just need you can just run
the copy pass this these commands it's
just to create a sandbox environment key
resources go in the project and in it
the project with it and everything and
from the first commit and then you can
create a variant or Conda and if you're
no use we will explain after that things
about the tutorial but if you can run
this part before we talk about the
pipeline it would be great because time
consuming tasks
yeah with setup especially if you use
income but come by you know they attend
to everything so a bit of time to done
that yeah and there's a do carry my
Jesus provided because if you don't run
in the do come in the docker container
and Python three menus dev is not
installed on your computer maybe you
will have an issue with the setup there
is no issue with Locanda come down
because come die under dependencies so
during setup state test we will talk
about such toil on its aim yes Vigo is
like to start with a typical state of a
project like when you're doing some
exploratory analysis and then you want
to like tidy things up and go all the
way to have a project on already
pipeline so we will we will cover a few
things mostly out to get from jupiter
notebooks to scripts and then to scripts
to GBC versioning and then I don't know
if we're gonna have time to like do the
other things but same does with the TVC
playground tutorial dollars a day to
continue and as
good question afterwards so this is like
really a toy projects it's based on
Schubert laser review which are
available in a JSON format and each of
this review is associated with a star
rating from 1 to 5 so we're going to do
classification because there's only 5
classes and yeah basically I mean a
choice you can discuss but the thing is
we're not trying to do like high level
data science we're just trying to to
showcase how can things can be done and
we've got a few steps so we're gonna
first extract things from the a JSON
format through a format which is going
to be very easy to use for training for
training we're going to use face book by
library called fast text to do some
classification basically because they
took files as input and output files and
so that's a good showcase for our
example and obviously we're going to
generate some metrics at the end to know
how good we did I think that's pretty
much it yep as everybody managed to at
least start the installation of the
environment can you raise your hand if
it's ok good so if you have a look at
the project structure probably be
something like that so you've got some
that books which are like the different
steps you want to do and you already
started to extract a bit of this that
books to a library for sharing like
loading and saving modules functions and
that kind of things but it's well it's a
in a mixed you know half-baked state
between really dodgy and really clean
and so we want you to try to improve
that
yes so until the MLV tools so first step
we need to run a GV seen it so
initialize the VC in the project okay so
here I am in the project I already could
be that yeah sorry and make the
initialization file step so I can reduce
units back its touches
oops okay
so the first thing to do it's a an
optional step but we will do it too
[Music]
because it will be easier next in the
tutorial we need to create a MLV tools
configuration file this file is used to
generate paths for the Python script and
DBC common automatically generate them
better than the path provided in the
configuration file and repeat on that
book name but it's totally optional you
can each time you run a command provide
this the output file you you want there
is more documentation about this
configuration file on a marriage will
get repository in there with me but but
just trust me for this step you can just
copy past those lines in the file name
dot MLV tools in the get root directory
and then added and committed
okay then we will create directories for
the scripts and the device for the
Python scripts and DBC commands and get
the data for the pipeline okay yeah and
so I am the data which a configuration
file and the TripAdvisor reviews then I
have the Python resources the notebooks
and the pipeline structure and now we
can do the fun part and have a look at
what is in the books
yes do we have any questions so far
yes yeah because you don't so sorry I
didn't think about that when I you can
always edit vinod book by home zippy the
gas CP I'm sorry for that I totally
forgot to tolling the oh you can just
expose 22 but we started a car exposed
to 22 per ton say to Jupiter netbooks to
start to Patong read books on this book
is is only other questions problems okay
let's have a look at what we are here
so first the extraction step
can you read good enough should make it
bigger then well basically we're using
this very nice function with roads which
you can extract things and so we've got
the if you review for overview for roll
files which are the extracted data is
very in a nicer format and as you can
see well it's kind of clean so it should
work so we've got data a lot of things
we've got hundred and sixty nine samples
I can extract it it's so we got from
this
she's an oral file to something which is
broken sentences by sentences with the
ratings at the beginning in the chapel
and so let's check all this go to same
number of samples my function is working
perfectly that's that's a good unit test
and just check things background very
good
and I can save this thing and the
problem is that my input and my outputs
were spread out all of our notebook
so when I opened that book why I opened
in that book I know what's happening
because I understand I wrote in that
book but when Stephanie is coming from
another project opening quickly but not
broke she's like what's being put lets
you outputs what's happening and wow we
can have a look of the other one which
pretty much the same for everything
where are things spread out all of our
in that book and yeah so there is like
all the steps we are shown so vu extract
your purpose as she's played you can
train and then you can evaluate your
model and so what we want to do first is
like to identify everything which is
input outputs parameters and then put
them at the top
hey you need to remove out coded values
from your netbooks it's just the first
step to use you can you need to have
something like configurable netbooks see
if from the first cell which are inputs
outputs and parameters which we can
change in this code to generate another
thing what is the dependencies of this
step do you have some questions so so
we're gonna do first a book together and
then you can do the other one because
it's a really fun activity so basically
the input is good and we want to excite
the output so we just put it's at top in
the variable and we're good to go yeah
we can just pass just create an extra
two data path variable okay it's really
simple and replace it so we're not gonna
need to do that for all of the netbooks
so it might seem a bit boring but
actually that's because we are going in
afterwards if you just take the abbot's
of always putting all the
external variables at the top when
you're watching the modification to do
is there is a little trap in split data
set here there is a parameter it's not
an idea but it need to be in the first
cell if you want to change it so
sometimes because it's a where we want
to split further training to just put
the train and test set but you can you
can do it by n but just because we don't
already at the time there is a shortcut
here and you can copy configurable
netbooks from the solution so is
everything good for everybody chill but
now we can version netbooks configurable
netbooks will get and so if you go back
to in that book in C now there is I oh
yeah input outputs and parameters so
here there is no MLP tools just remove a
decoded path remove out coded parameters
from netbooks and now to be able to use
elevators we need it's quite magical but
you still need to write some things as
we said before there is three main
commands in M LV tools you can see them
in ml visual documentation but yeah we
will use a comment to generate both
Python configurable and executive your
script and the GBC comment and so you
know we need to add some information how
do we add some information to help and
other tools is just we add the doc
string to specify which which variables
are parameters so if we take
examples split data set netbook you can
see there is this loose information in
the first cut cell and we will need to
say to a malva tool which which
variables are script parameters and we
will do that through the ducts rings
sorry
the syntax is this one there is some
optional things like the parameter type
and the parameter description but and we
will have this thing in the first cut
cell I will explain it I could be passed
it yeah so yeah okay here we have
proposes that a pass with chill which is
a an input of this notebook and we can
declare it as a Python arguments saying
it's a string arguments we provide this
name its name and a short description
same thing for train data pass data set
pass which is an output test data set
path and test percent which is a float
and which is an argument of there and a
parameter and a parameter you I can save
the netbook so this thing is to say to a
mere virtual which will be per meter for
the Python free executable command
it's it's needed by the EPI and be to
Python common to if you inv to python
MLV tools to so that then you generate
these - scripts you can actually provide
all these parameters to the Python
script if like you want to rerun the
step and I increase the text size and
use that to instead of dot 15 you can
you don't have to rewrote and or open
and change out great value in your
networks you can just change things on
the fly
but if you want to also generate the GBC
common you need to say to the VC which
parameter are DC dependencies
do you see step dependencies and the VC
step outputs so you need to add some
information in the in the dog string so
yeah this part okay so about the syntax
here we have a DC in is a dependency so
pre-process data path which is also a is
a dependency of this test this step so
we need to declare it and we provide the
path to this file where I achieve to the
top to the git repository would and same
principle with the output path output
files and we can provide some extra
parameters because the Python command
needs the test persons argument all
things in this cell after the dog string
will be discard in the Python script
those values are just for the purpose a
netbook just so you are still able to
run it in the notebook and you can see
path and that exists exactly the same
because we are not in the top level
directory yeah yeah there is something
something more this deck strength can
use ginger tampering
we will not show it yeah but it's in the
documentation so you can use variable
here from a configuration file and I'll
use those viable yeah so there is no
inconsistency no risk of inconsistency
but it's a another subject and just as
you can seem like a bit too a lot of
tried but actually it can help you to
like sequence how your pipeline is going
and next you think about which are the
dependence
each step and your dependency graph and
it's really interesting or so from that
a sense point of view so this vision of
how things are flowing through and which
are shared dependency and which are
distinct dependencies and it's actually
like you write it once and it's not that
long because then you can reuse your
notebooks and you're not always starting
from scratch
for example repossessing stead can be
the same for all of your training
pipelines if you've got the same input
data so it's a bit of work but at the
beginning but you you win a lot of time
afterwards because things get easier and
faster all information are centralized
in the network is there any questions or
any things which it seems unclear
tonight it's okay I will show the result
will generate the Python script and the
and the GBC comment from the netbook so
I run the EP ynb to GBC common with a
notebook as input and I let the script
generate output path with the
configuration file okay now if I run it
three on the pipeline structure I can
see there is a disagreement and the
Python script
okay no surprise the Python script is in
fact come on you can really retriever
arguments process data paths with a
short description and we can have a look
at the juicy common but it's it's quite
complex because there is some mechanism
you don't really need to know about but
here is the GBC step called divvy
surrender step call with a Python
command and the
it's we don't have to know what happened
oh yeah but there is something wrong
here if we have a look at the Python
script we can see there is a lot of
sorry we can see there is a lot of no
effect statement we don't want this kind
of statement in a non-interactive run
there's no interest but you still want
to keep them in the netbooks because
when you are developing around a
debugging we want to be able to have the
length of the things are sure no data
frame or maybe some nice Instagram plots
other kind of things so we don't want to
remove them entirely but we don't have
room to add them in our automated
pipeline run so to discount this kind of
statement where you can add this comment
in the cell in the netbook cell you want
to discard and they will be they will be
removed from the generated Python script
so they you in the configuration file if
you don't want to say no effect and you
want to to say the discard what is
unique and you can configure it
oops
like that you are still able to run Zeus
selling you netbooks but if I regenerate
files this - F because they already
exist I can see now I forgot one but
there is no there is no but no effect
cells are discarded well I think if you
want to raise some unit testing it's
still easier to do that only once
because these kind of scripts are very
good for functional testing but you
can't really like test unitary each
micro step I think you need to find a
balance between between function for
example like speak that I said yeah you
want to put in the Python module to
reuse it but maybe you want to run a
functional test on this step and you can
do it because there is a function yeah
which represent the netbook execution
maybe thing would be like a typical
workflow I mean we want to version
things at all steps starting from the
very exploratory thing all the way to
the production setting and the idea is
obviously when you're in a very
exploratory step you can rush on things
using a Velva tools but you don't have
you have few tests and that kind of
thing and the idea is as your pipeline
gets more mature
you are encouraged to take out things
from the netbook and in the end in our
production-ready netbooks we've got like
two cells in our scripts which are these
dog strings cell and the other cell is
like in part this function from our
library and use it under input and then
all you've got all the cells below which
might be vera not which are no effect
cells and which are like now that I run
with for example pre-processing step I
want to check that everything went right
because it's like new customer that I
have never seen before and I'm still
using the same jupiter netbook but when
it's the script is like a very short
script and everything is outsources to
this library to this - module which is
tested but when I'm running a new data I
can get this I can do my import pandas
and have a look at my data frame and
check everything and check how many
missing values and I've and plot all the
things I want to have infinite book
always or dislike the time monitoring
things we want to do and it's still
available every time in the same
notebook which is shared by everyone but
the discreet but in itself has no
basically no current legend when that
book is just like a windows open on your
data to check was what is happening at
every step of the pipeline i may just
take a shortcut - yeah you can copy or
netbooks with ml virtual doctoring and
generate for just netbooks or the
pipeline script by pipeline python sweet
and juicy step and so yeah you have this
structure where is type python script
and steps
I just want to show you how to run the
pipeline
I had everything okay so now I can type
pipeline inputs with DBC as we did it in
a novice tutorial but and then just run
each GVC step we we have generated in
the pipeline structure I'll go quickly
so we just remove tomato results because
or else I will consider it's already
here and so we get an error and you need
to rerun the step with minus F and since
there are a lot of step you don't want
to rerun them we just want to copy race
thing
just to show you we have a PVC pipe line
all right
you can see yeah we have a DC pipeline
yeah so absolutely it's too long and we
can explain everything
but with the basic DC command you you
run once on your project you can build
GVC pipeline with all information
centralized in your netbooks and I was
with the script you can take advantages
of your development environment for
refactoring and things like that to know
where function are used you can write
tests and after that you can use the
feature of division reproduce any
experiments and yet just to the end of
this tutorial which we won't have time
to finish if you go back to the pipeline
thing yeah and which is not just about
writing tests because we we don't like
to write tests but the very magical
thing is if I change something in my
configuration file like if I change so
in the trends type can I use a learning
rate like basically almost every machine
learning algorithm and if you want to
treat your learning rates when you're
trying what you can do is basically just
create a new kid branch and change his
value add the file wave DVC with the new
value and then we run the experiment and
you can have all of your experiments
which are - on side by side and so that
you can check which learning rake is
watching is working best and that's
really very powerful because then you
can iterate very quickly and with a lot
of confidence about like I didn't that's
I'm not mistaken I
I can run experiments even quite late in
the night and I'm confident advised I'm
that's using the wrong file and then my
experiment is running all night and in
the morning and like oh no that's not
what I wanted to run so between each
branches yeah that's really the one of
his strong point of using DVC is having
this possibility to explore a yew tree a
combination of hyperparameters
and then envy and choose which one is
working best and merge it back into your
main I mean master branch and and you
don't have to keep track this yeah I
don't know how you do out doing it but I
was doing it with like an excel file or
something where you unsure by hand I
prepare metals and try to see which one
is the best and then you try to do this
great thing and just gets Messier and
Messier at some time you're like okay I
will just pick one combination on that
run them and hope it's quite good it
really allows you to iterate more
quickly and gets better results much
faster there is a feature in ml the
tools you can export the pipeline soon
you will be able to export a pipeline
and package this pipeline with a Debian
packages or con data caches it's under
development you can also add a get book
command to check there is always a
consistency between your generated
script and the chapitre netbooks because
it's essential and we are really waiting
for your poor request or for your
feature request yeah I mean if you don't
feel like writing a peer but you've got
this use case which which is very
important to you and it's not covered we
definitely want to err button here I
thought that to be able to see if we can
improve for example we can use tip
eternal book tags instead of comments
for two discs and no effects or
something like that
[Applause]